solarenergie auch photovoltaik genannt
galt lange zeit als unzuverlässig und
teuer aber das völlig zu unrecht wie ein
forschungsteam jetzt zeigt demnach ist
photovoltaik viel besser als ihr ruf und
eine der am schnellsten wachsenden
erneuerbaren energien überhaupt die
prognose der forscherinnen und forscher
für die solarenergie in naher zukunft
ist sensationell und übertrifft bei
weitem alle bisherigen erwartungen welch
unglaubliches potenzial in der
solarenergie gesehen wird und ob damit
der klimawandel vielleicht sogar noch zu
stoppen ist jetzt den krieg zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
der klimawandel kann wohl nur noch
aufgehalten oder zumindest verlangsamt
werden wenn wir möglichst schnell auf
erneuerbare energien umschwenken
darüber haben wir ja schon öfter
berichte genauso wie über die
verschiedenen energieformen wie wind und
solarenergie
die neben ihren ganzen vorteilen auch
schattenseiten haben denn diese art der
stromerzeugung ist natürlich stark vom
wetter abhängig
die herausforderung für das stromnetz
besteht darin die schwankungen
abzupuffern und auszugleichen
beispielsweise in dem der strom
zwischengespeichert wird oder in andere
regionen in denen er gerade benötigt
wird weitergeleitet wird doch das gilt
als extrem kostenintensiv und aufwendig
und schade dem image der photovoltaik
nachhaltig doch es tut sich was in
sachen solarenergie
das zeigt jetzt eine große studie des
berliner forschungsinstituts mercator
research institute in global commons and
climate change kurz mcc die
forscherinnen und forscher haben mit
einem computerprogramm gearbeitet in das
sie aktuelle daten zum beispiel
solarenergie gespeist haben
hierbei wurden beispielsweise die kosten
für den netzausbau speicher optionen und
informationen über den bereits
vorhandenen photovoltaik ausbau sehr
detailliert berücksichtigt und ihr
ergebnis ist extrem spannend ihrer
studien zufolge könnte der anteil der
photovoltaik an der globalen
stromversorgung in zukunft 30 wie
sagenhafte 50 prozent ausmachen selbst
wenn der weltweite bedarf an strom
weiter zunimmt eine unglaubliche zahl
wenn man bedenkt dass früher berechnung
von läppischen 5 bis 17 prozent
ausgegangen waren und weiter das
wachstumspotenzial der photovoltaik
seien mit unglaublichen 40% jährlich
anzusetzen so das ergebnis der neuen
studie
doch aus welchen gründen wurden die
solarenergie so sehr unterschätzt
das wissenschaftsteam hat auch dazu
antworten parat fördermaßnahmen wie das
erneuerbare energien gesetz in
deutschland hätten genauso wie ähnliche
konzepte in anderen ländern viel mehr
bewirkt als man bislang angenommen hat
zum anderen verzeichnet das
forschungsteam einen krassen boom bei
privatleuten die solarenergie
mittlerweile als eine lohnende
investition erkannt haben der studie
zufolge gehört
bereits im jahr 2012 knapp die hälfte
der vorhandenen photovoltaik kapazität
privatleuten weit mehr als bei jeder
anderen stromerzeugung technologie als
weiteren punkt nennt das forschungsteam
die technische und preisliche
entwicklung der solarzellen jede
verdopplung der installierten kapazität
bedeutet eine reduzierung der kosten und
knapp ein viertel
die folge davon die kosten für
hausgemachten solarstrom könnten so
tatsächlich die des konventionellen
stroms aus dem netz unterbieten und so
sei der solarstrom selbst in ländern wie
indien oder chile bereits heute schon
deutlich preiswerter als der strom aus
konventionellen kraftwerken und das
ganze ohne subventionen und nicht nur
der aktuelle status quo zu solarenergie
übertrifft laut der studie alle
erwartungen auch die konkreten prognosen
für die nahe zukunft sind ja man muss
sagen grandios bis zum jahr 2050 sollen
tatsächlich bis zu 50 prozent der
weltweiten stromerzeugung aus
photovoltaik kommen konkret sollen sie
18.000 bis 36.000 terawattstunden
liefern und das zu vertretbaren kosten
vor allem in südlichen ländern sei das
potenzial für die solarenergie zu großen
teilen noch unausgeschöpfte aber auch in
deutschland und europa bescheinigt das
forschungsteam der photovoltaik noch ein
großes potenzial vor allem die
kombination aus wind und solarenergie
sei optimal durch extreme sonne im
sommer und stärkeren wind im frühjahr
und herbst könne eine ausgeglichene
stromerzeugung garantiert werden heißt
also im klartext der überschuss an strom
wird durch diese kombi so gering wie
möglich gehalten genauso wie die hohen
kosten um den strom zu speichern aber
können diese möglichkeiten der
solarenergie in der praxis überhaupt
voll und ganz ausgeschöpft werden
es wäre fast zu schön um wahr zu sein
denn nur wenn wir erneuerbaren energien
eine chance geben können wir abstand von
risikoreichen technologien wie der
atomkraft nehmen die masche liche
stromerzeugung aus kohle minimieren oder
sogar ganz abschaffen und damit den
klimawandel ernst nehmen denn das
solarenergie umweltfreundlich ist steht
schließlich schon ziemlich lang fest
jetzt liegt es also an der wirtschaft
und politik die weichen dafür zu stellen
und somit den pariser klimaschutzzielen
eine
realistische chance zu geben auch mit
hilfe der solarenergie und ihrem enormen
entwicklungspotential konkret müssten
dafür stabilere netze und größere
speicherkapazitäten geschaffen werden
technologien für neue speicher methoden
müssten gefördert werden und neue
regularien für den elektrizitäts markt
geschaffen werden und irgendwie ist es
ja schon ein wenig peinlich dass der bau
von kohlekraftwerken in ländern wie
indien bereits zum teil gestoppt wird um
stattdessen auf solarenergie zu setzen
auch wenn die investitionskosten erst
einmal hoch erscheinen denn nicht
zuletzt diese studie zeigt dass mit
hilfe der photovoltaik der grundstein zu
einer klimafreundlichen und preiswerten
stromerzeugung gelegt werden könnte
hierbei klicks um halte ich euch
natürlich zu dem thema auf dem laufenden
wenn er kein video dazu und auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke der
mieter nichts verpassen und immer
nachrichten bekommen wenn ein neues
video erscheint hier geht es weiter mit
was interessiert mich das klima response
in folge 05 das sprechen der
klimaforscher mojib latif und ich über
den klimawandel und wie nötig es ist
etwas zu tun ein sehr aufschlussreiches
video der bundeszentrale für politische
bildung unbedingt anschauen da besteht
also guf licht also bis dann bleibt dran